¿Por qué las crisis constantes de hoy
no nos incentivan a la acción?
¿Por qué no nos impulsan?
En especial cuando se trata del cambio climático.
Así que hoy quiero hablarles
de lo que creo que es una receta de transformación, mucho más completa,
catalizada por eventos estremecedores.
Y voy a concentrarme en dos ingredientes claves
frecuentemente dejados de lado en los libros de historia.
Uno se relaciona con la imaginación, el otro se relaciona con la organización;
porque en la interacción entre ambos
yace el poder revolucionario.
Comencemos con la imaginación.
Las victorias del Nuevo Trato no ocurrieron solo porque repentinamente
todos entendieran las brutalidades del "laissez-faire".
Recordemos, esa fue una época de tremenda agitación ideológica,
en la que muchas ideas diferentes sobre cómo organizar la sociedad
luchaban unas con otras en la esfera pública.
Un tiempo en el que la humanidad se atrevió a soñar en grande
sobre los distintos tipos de futuros,
muchos de ellos organizados por principios igualitarios radicales.
Ahora bien, no todas esas ideas eran buenas
pero fue una época de imaginación explosiva.
Esto significó que los movimientos que exigían un cambio
sabían contra qué luchaban: pobreza devastadora, desigualdad creciente...
Pero tan importante como eso, sabían a favor de qué estaban.
Sabían a qué decían "no" y a qué decían "sí", también.
También tenían modelos de organización política muy diferentes
a los de hoy en día.
Por décadas, los movimientos sociales y del trabajo
habían estado construyendo las bases de su afiliación,
incorporando causas e incrementando su fuerza.
Cuando la Depresión ocurrió, significó
que ya había un movimiento lo suficientemente grande y extenso
para, por ejemplo, hacer huelgas que no solo cerraron fábricas,
sino que paralizaron ciudades enteras.
Los logros de la gran política del "Nuevo Trato" se volvieron compromisos
porque la alternativa parecía ser la revolución.
Así que, ajustemos la ecuación anterior.
Un evento estremecedor más imaginación utópica,
más trabajo arduo,
así es como damos un verdadero salto.
Y, ¿cómo evaluamos nuestro momento actual?
Estamos viviendo, otra vez, en una época de extraordinario compromiso político.
La política es una obsesión masiva.
Los movimientos progresistas están creciendo y resistiendo valientemente.
Sin embargo, gracias a la historia sabemos que un "no" no es suficiente.
Ahora bien, hay algunos "sí" que están emergiendo allá afuera
y se están volviendo más audaces rápidamente.
Mientras los activistas del cambio climático hablaban de cambiar bombillas,
ahora luchamos para que el 100 % de nuestra energía
provenga del sol, viento y olas,
y queremos que sea pronto.
Los movimientos causados por la violencia policíaca hacia personas de color
exigen que se ponga fin a la policía militarizada, la encarcelación masiva,
e incluso que se repare el daño de la esclavitud.
Los estudiantes no solo se oponen a los incrementos en las colegiaturas,
en Chile, Canadá, el Reino Unido,
exigen que las colegiaturas sean gratuitas y que se les anulen los adeudos.
Sin embargo, esto aún no contribuye
al tipo de visión holística y universal
de un mundo distinto del que nuestros predecesores tuvieron.
¿A qué se debe eso?
Bueno, muy a menudo pensamos en el cambio político
como en compartimentos delimitados hoy en día.
El medio ambiente en una caja, la desigualdad en otra,
la justicia racial y de género en otras dos cajas,
la educación por aquí, la salud por allá.
Y en cada compartimento,
hay miles de miles de grupos de diferentes ONG
compitiendo las unas con las otras por créditos, prestigio,
y claro, recursos.
En otras palabras, nos comportamos muy parecido a las marcas corporativas.
A menudo a esto se le refiere como el problema de los silos.
Los silos son fáciles de entender.
Organizan nuestro mundo complejo en pedacitos digeribles.
Nos ayudan a sentirnos menos agobiados.
Pero en el proceso, también enseñan a nuestro cerebro a desconectarse
de los problemas de los demás
cuando los problemas ajenos necesitan nuestra ayuda y apoyo.
Y también nos impiden ver las conexiones evidentes entre nuestros problemas.
Por ejemplo, la gente que lucha contra la pobreza y desigualdad
rara vez habla del cambio climático.
Aunque veamos una y otra vez
que la gente más pobre
es la más vulnerable al clima extremo.
Los activistas del cambio climático rara vez hablan de guerra y ocupación.
Aunque sepamos que la sed de combustibles fósiles
ha sido una causa importante de conflicto.
El movimiento verde nos ha señalado cada vez más claramente
que los países más afectados por el cambio climático
están poblados en su gran mayoría por gente de color.
Pero cuando a la vida de la gente de color se le concibe como desechable
en las prisiones, escuelas o calles,
rara vez hacemos estas conexiones.
Los muros que dividen los silos
hacen que nuestras soluciones, cuando éstas emergen,
también estén desconectadas las unas de las otras.
Los progresistas ahora tienen una larga lista de demandas, como mencioné antes,
esos "sí".
Pero lo que aún no vemos
es una imagen articulada del mundo por el que luchamos.
De cómo luce, de cómo se siente, y sobre todo, de sus valores fundamentales.
Y eso realmente importa.
Porque cuando las crisis a gran escala nos afectan
y enfrentamos la necesidad de movernos a un lugar más seguro,
no sabemos con certeza cuál es ese lugar.
Y movernos sin destino fijo
es como saltar de arriba a abajo.
(Risas)
Afortunadamente, hay todo tipo de diálogos y experimentos en marcha
tratando de superar las divisiones que nos retienen.
Quiero finalizar hablándoles de una de ellas.
Hace unos años, un grupo de nosotros en Canadá
decidimos que estábamos llegando a un límite
de lo que podíamos lograr en nuestros diversos silos.
Así que nos encerramos en una habitación durante dos días,
y tratamos de averiguar qué nos unía.
En esa habitación había gente que rara vez se encuentra junta.
Había indígenas mayores con hipsters que trabajan en tránsito.
Estaba el director de Greenpeace
con un líder sindical que representaba a empleados petroleros y leñadores.
Había líderes religiosos e iconos feministas y muchos otros.
Y nos dimos a la ambiciosa tarea
de convenir en una descripción breve del mundo, después de que triunfáramos;
del mundo después de que hubiéramos hecho la transición a una economía verde
y hacia una sociedad más justa.
En otras palabras,
en vez de asustar a la gente sobre lo que pasaría si no actuáramos,
decidimos tratar de inspirarla.
La gente sabia siempre dice
que el cambio debe darse en pequeñas cantidades,
que la política es el arte de lo posible,
y que no debemos dejar que la perfección sea la enemiga de lo bueno.
Bien, nosotros renegamos de todo eso.
Escribimos un manifiesto, y lo nombramos "Dar el salto".
Tengo que decirles, convenir en un "sí" en común,
proveniente de experiencias tan diversas
y con un telón de fondo de una historia muy dolorosa,
no fue un trabajo sencillo.
Pero fue también muy emocionante.
Porque en cuanto nos permitimos soñar,
esos hilos conectores de nuestro trabajo se hicieron evidentes.
Nos dimos cuenta, por ejemplo,
de que la interminable búsqueda de ingresos
que obliga a tanta gente a trabajar más de 50 horas a la semana,
sin seguridad,
y que aviva la epidemia de la desesperanza,
es la misma búsqueda insaciable de ganancias e infinito crecimiento
que está en el centro de nuestra crisis ecológica
y desestabilización del planeta.
También vimos claro qué hace falta hacer.
Necesitamos crear una cultura del cuidado.
En la que nadie ni nada sea desechado.
En la que el valor inherente de la gente y de todos los ecosistemas sea la base.
Así que creamos esta plataforma,
--no se preocupen, no voy a leerles todo en voz alta--
si les interesa, pueden leerlo en la página theleap.org.
Pero les voy a dar una probadita de lo que creamos.
Exigimos a la brevedad que la economía sea 100 % renovable,
pero fuimos más lejos.
Exigimos nuevas formas de comercio,
un debate serio sobre un ingreso anual garantizado,
todos los derechos para trabajadores inmigrantes,
desvincular el dinero corporativo de la política,
guarderías gratuitas universales, una reforma electoral y más.
Descubrimos que la gran mayoría de nosotros
estamos buscando permiso para actuar menos como marcas y más como movimientos.
Porque a los movimientos no les importa el crédito.
Quieren difundir buenas ideas a lo largo y ancho.
Lo que me encanta de "Dar el salto"
es que rechaza la idea de que hay una jerarquía de crisis,
no da prioridad a ninguna lucha sobre otra,
ni las pone en espera.
Y aunque nació en Canadá,
hemos descubierto que es universal.
Desde su lanzamiento, "Dar el salto" ha sido adoptado en otros lados
con plataformas similares,
ha sido escrito desde Nunavut a Australia,
Noruega, el Reino Unido, EE. UU.,
y está ganando mucha fuerza en ciudades como Los Ángeles,
donde se está volviendo local.
Y también en comunidades rurales tradicionalmente muy conservadoras,
y donde la política le esté fallando a la gente.
Esto he aprendido estudiando crisis y desastres durante dos décadas.
Las crisis nos ponen a prueba.
O nos desmoronamos o crecemos rápido.
Encontramos una fuerza y una capacidad que no sabíamos que teníamos.
Los eventos estremecedores que nos llenan de temor hoy en día
pueden transformarnos, y pueden transformar el mundo para bien.
Pero primero necesitamos vislumbrar el mundo por el que luchamos.
Y tenemos que soñarlo juntos.
En este momento, todas las alarmas en nuestra casa se han activado.
Es momento de escuchar.
Es momento de dar un salto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)